[Music]
how does a person
who escapes from
slavery create a literary masterpiece
seven years later language for douglas
first came of course orally
he's taught to read and write first by
sophia old in baltimore when he was
seven eight nine years old finding the
colombian order was absolutely crucial
that book was a true treasure to him and
then he attends uh four different
churches in baltimore when he's a
teenager
he was learning some
level of homolytics preaching before he
ever left baltimore and then we also
know that you know when he's about 18
and he's stranded on the
freeland farm but it's there that he
developed
that he called it his band of brothers a
group that they'd go off on every sunday
and he would read out loud to them what
do you think the effect of being sent
from
the
relative freedom of
life in the city right to the plantation
to the fields well he was when he was 15
years old yeah he sent back to the
eastern shore
he was
desperate then he turned into
an angry uncontrollable teenager who has
seen the city
he's seen this relative freedom of
movement of imagination
and no doubt he had friends already
but it's like his imagination was
crushed he also studied avidly
newspapers particularly absolutely
william lloyd garrison's the liberator
so he's reading it like we read the new
york times he's reading the liberator
assiduously which is a weekly
uh every week when he's 20 21 22 years
old in new bedford even tells us he
tacked it on the wall when he worked on
that foundry right he'd work the bellows
with one arm and
read the liberator you know to the side
would it be anachronistic to call
frederick douglass america's first
celebrity uh he's certainly one of them
i mean pt barnum might want to claim
some piece of that
but douglas did become a creature of
great fame such that he was not only so
recognizable
especially after he appeared on the
cover of harpers
which was the 19th century version of
the cover of you know time magazine or
whatever there's also we have to
remember his travels were so ubiquitous
you know i went sat down and tried to
start tabulating the sheer number of
miles oh my god i was trying to come up
with the average winter tour was about
three to four thousand miles and so how
many years i quit
it's thousands hundreds of thousands of
miles but i do speculate in the book
that probably more americans heard
douglas speak
than any other american speaker and this
fame was a problem of course especially
in washington d.c especially in relation
to his family and especially in relation
to aspects of his personal life
it's a life where he has to eventually
calculate okay what do i say here for
public consumption and what can i say
that's not for public consumption
i do think douglas in fact i have no
doubt douglas felt the responsibility of
being this representative man
i also think he never stopped pursuing
who the hell am i
i am from the eastern shore i'm nobody
from the tuckahoe river but i'm look
where i am now
how did i get here how did a slave from
the tuckahoe river end up in speaking in
the greatest halls in edinburgh london
and and new york but he clearly was what
we would call a celebrity especially
later in life how important do you think
his legacy
was to him by the end oh very important
you don't write
life and times in 1881 and re
rewrite it with six more chapters in
1892 if you're not concerned about your
legacy he makes a lot of speeches toward
the end of his life where you can read
them as summations of his life
he does many many eulogies of other
abolitionists
there's no question he dies at a time
when
the great victories of emancipation the
war and reconstruction the remaking of
the united states is in great danger
southern redemption is complete
disfranchisement is spreading across the
south lynching is spreading across the
south he had every right to say we have
completely lost but he never really does
that
and again i think what sustained douglas
to the bitter end
was that he was the product of two deep
great traditions
one is the secular enlightenment
natural rights tradition which is
practically in everything he wrote and
spoke
and then the biblical tradition
faith
that somehow
you know no matter what happens to you
no matter if the temple is destroyed
no matter if your best efforts
are betrayed you can't give up
you have to stay with it you have to
have faith
[Music]
you